simone est ce que vous pouvez pas juste
nous faire d'abord pour camille et moi
je voudrais qu'on se prenne par la main
et que vous vous sentiez juste comme ça
on l'a cappellois entre nous c'était bon
de rire entre nous attend ce moment de
rires ouais bon pour ton bon j'avais
chanté dans les chairs vous c'est le
temps qui s'enfuit qui s'en fout c'est
la vie qui nous prend dans son pauvre
c'est le coeur qui a déjà fait l'amour
sur une chanson de chimène badi quoi
vous bah oui quoi sur laquelle m'arrive
encore sur l'accueil mais justement
c'est pas une bonne chanson pour ça
c'est quoi était la reprise de la rdo
sud 2 assure que ces ballons connaissent
pas du tout le rythme qui est adapté on
rappelle les paroles parce que c'est
vrai que ça ça se prête bien à l'amour
rappelé les paroles joder du sud et
partout les chemins girouille entière
[Applaudissements]
employé road ans
[Musique]
toujours la cadence
je le courrai vous l'avez déjà pu aussi
sur une chanson de chimène badi a fait
l'amour
enfin j'étais tout seul avec la pochette
[Applaudissements]
une fois restaurée ans j'ai fait tourner
les boules à la banlieue
chimène badi au delà des
[Rires]